[Music]
the guardians of the galaxy movies are
interesting because everyone has that
one that they absolutely adore and
another one that they think is okay
some adore the first one think the
sequels okay some adore the second and
think the first ones okay me I'm a
volume two kind of guy I absolutely love
this movie sense of humor its drama its
visual its effects its characters its
pacing its themes I just fell in love
with it
our team of spaced outcasts are back
fighting all sorts of monsters and weird
creatures and always on the run but when
trying to find a place to hide out they
come across a celestial name ego played
by Kurt Russell Russell it's revealed is
star Lord's father yeah I guess you
can't expect a guy like this to have
normal parents his abilities are pretty
much that of a God he can create worlds
from nothing he can also destroy them
with nothing would suggest a very large
threat but the guy seems pretty nice he
gives them all a place to stay he's a
jokester he's kind but part of the
situation something just doesn't seem
right nobody can put their finger on it
but there just seems to be something a
little off everybody except of course
star-lord who just loves that he's found
his actual dead and he's discovering who
he is where he came from and what he's
gonna do next but meanwhile the guy who
raised our Lord yondu played again by
Michael Rooker is in the middle of a
mutiny with his crew taking over his
ship and even capturing Groot and Rocket
while they desperately tried to escape
and even for him a little bit of a bond
star-lord desperately tries to form a
bond and maybe things about trying to
escape it's one of those setups I love
where you feel like a prisoner but you
can never actually say you are you can
go at any time it doesn't seem like
you're really being threatened yet
somehow it feels like you're being held
against your will
of course secrets are discover betrayals
are made jokes are head and giant
intergalactic battles involving pac-man
appear because that shit can work in a
movie like this what drew me the most of
this film is not only that the sense of
humor seemed to really be up I mean the
first film was very funny but this one
seemed especially funny but the drama
really seemed up to to a lot of the
movie is just kind of taking it easy in
these incredible environments and really
letting them sink in I really like films
where the visuals kind of tell you this
door
the background is almost as big a
character one of my favorite scenes is a
really quiet moment where Kimora is just
sitting in this field and then suddenly
the ship comes down and attacks and it's
her sibling and they try shooting at
each other and blowing each other up but
then they both kind of get tired they
talk with one another and they make
amends like siblings do it's crazy and
over-the-top yet somehow it feels kind
of real the emotions are all there and
they don't need to be talked about they
just need to be explored you can learn
just as much about a character with a
few choice words and just seeing them
walk alone than you can with paragraphs
and paragraphs of dialogue with that
said there are a few things that don't
quite add up for example I love Michael
Rooker in this film I mean he's just a
great character in this but then there's
kind of this connection that he was
always his dad and he raised star-lord
but I don't know the first film did not
make that connection very strongly I
know they say like he was hard on him
because he cared about him but it feels
like they're retconning the last film
but kind of make this comparison work
but honestly it's okay because it's done
so well in this film I love the way all
these relations work off each other and
they're all so unique and they're so
well defined we're in the first movie a
lot of the drama seemed to just be at
the beginning a little bit in the middle
and then a little bit at the end and
they just kind of came out of nowhere
here it seems balanced perfectly they
can go from one funny moment to an
incredibly heartbreaking moment in just
a millisecond that way a gigantic battle
between a father and son God and human
can easily be interrupted by just
showing Groot how to push a button they
both work match up beautifully and you
care for everybody even the ending scene
which I won't give away I'm not gonna
lie I got a little teary eyed at somehow
this movie was working its magic without
me even realizing it to a point where
when a character disappeared I felt
really bad I felt as emotional as the
characters in the film did and a lot of
that is because we do like these
characters and we do understand where
they're coming from and they're strange
and they're weird and they're outcasts
and they're goofy but we can relate to
all of it if I have one gripe it's that
the ending does go on a little too long
and maybe they're making up for the fact
that
of the action was saved for the end and
there's only bits and pieces and the
rest of the film like I said it is a lot
of walking around and talking so I guess
they felt they had to make up for lost
punching time and just throw it all in
the third act but still that action is
amazing and it's so incredible to watch
and you're 100% on the characters side
you want to see them work through what
they're working through you want to see
them make connections you want to see
them win you want to see them succeed so
yeah I can't say if you like the first
one you're gonna love the second one
because I know a lot of people that love
the first one think the second one is
only okay but I also know a lot of
people that think the first one's okay
like me and absolutely adore the second
one and I don't know what it is but each
film has something unique that connects
with a lot of people so whether you want
to shoot a blaster or shed a tear this
is a movie that definitely takes you to
the studs
[Music]
you